hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that happened yesterday
on chess.com between John Lewis hammer
and Magnus Carlsen uh it's uh really a
spectacular game both of them are
Norwegian I I think they're also friends
I don't know to what extent but I
believe they are uh you all know Magnus
is the world champion of everything
world champion of classical Blitz and
Rapid chess and you only Ludwig Hammer
uh he is uh third highest rated player
in Norway behind Magnus Crossing in the
audientari and this game is absolutely
spectacular I already said that but it
truly is and one uh moment of pure
carelessness allows a hammer to really
execute a beautiful beautiful
checkmating sequence
um I chose the the happiest photo I
could find of hammer for this video
um I I imagine he was much much happier
than this but this is the best I could
do so imagine him much much happier as
you are watching this game especially as
the game progresses uh past a certain
point so let's check it out a hammer
with the white pieces opens with E4
Magnus goes for his signature g6.0 batch
defense for the modern defense D4 with
E6 Knight to F3 and now there are a lot
of moves that can be played here Magnus
chooses one that has never been played
before already on move 3 we have a
completely new game Magnus goes for
Knight to E7 now let's see how a hammer
deals with this novelty he goes for H4
and of course why wouldn't you you
already have a Target on G6 Magnus plays
H6 and now Bishop to F4 nicely
developing pieces with Bishop to G7 and
now uh Queen to D2 that makes sense you
prevent the Magnus from castling as the
H6 Pawn is now a Target we have D5 by
Magnus E5 uh Ludwig
grabs more space in the center and the
Magnus strikes against the center with
Pawn to C5 we have C3 and now Knight
beat to C6 Magnus nicely continuous
development Knight to A3 now with ideas
of maybe bringing the Knight over to D6
and while you might expect something
like A6 here Magnus plays this in a
completely different he goes King to f8
and now he is basically inviting the
Knight to come to D6 but Ludwig I
imagine trusted Magnus he just continues
the game the captains and C5 it's a free
Pawn so why not and the Magnus uh gives
up another one at uh to help with the
development of his pieces so see
captures on B6 Queen captures and now
Bishop to D3 uh preparing to put more
pressure on that King side Bishop to A6
trying to trade off whites a very strong
light Square bishop and Hammer goes for
B4 he's preparing B5 to win material
here but the problem is Magnus uh sorry
Hammer has a lot of pieces on weird
squares the bishop on F4 is weird ended
the Knight on A3 is weird and that's
what allows Magnus to just ignore his
threat and he plays D4 now the problem
is uh this doesn't work but it's very
hard to see why a hammer goes for B5 he
goes for the attack on the bishop and
the Knight and not just the D captures
in C3 attacking magnus's Queen Hammer's
Queen and uh what Hammer should do here
is play Queen to E2
uh he played Queen to E3 he offered a
queen trade because why wouldn't you as
both of the pieces are hanging but Queen
to E2 is actually the correct move here
it's a it's a really fun line because
now after Knight to D4 okay you save one
piece let's say Knight captures Queen
captures and now the bishop on F4 will
be hanging as well but the problem is
there's Bishop to E3 attacks the queen
and now you have to play Queen to A4 you
have to capture an A6 Queen captures on
A3 and now you just castle and you have
a much much better if not straight out
winning position with white as the black
king is in a terrible terrible uh Square
on f8 but okay it's a Blitz game Queen
to E3 was played and here Magnus just
goes for Knight to D5 he attacks the
queen forces the queen trade which also
attacks the bishop on F4 that's why I
said the pieces were on uh well maybe
sub-optimal squares Queen captures on B6
a captures on B6 and now just B captures
an A6 grabbing that Bishop but now
Magnus is very happy he captures an F4
threatens to capture the bishop on D3
Bishop to E4 is played attacking the
Knight also the Knight cannot move and
now just The Rook captures an A6 by
Magnus and now hammers the Knight on A3
is also hanging so Bishop captures on C6
with Rook captures on A3 and now uh
hammer just castles Queen side and now
if you look at the position okay
magnus's King is still on f8 but it's
not really that big of a deal he can
just put the King on H7 and bring the
Rook into the game or so you would think
Magnus starts with King to G8 and Hammer
goes with the immediate The Rook to d8
with check and now Magnus goes into a
moment of complete carelessness and he
plays King the H7 the problem is you
have to block this with Bishop to f8 and
then the game continues you will also
you also have the past C Pawn so uh
objectively Black's position is
completely winning here however Magnus
puts his King on H7 and he completely
overlooks something spectacular it's
actually a 4 forced mate in 11 for
Hammer so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this idea while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the exact
mate in 11 although it's a really
unnecessary black would have to give up
a whole lot of unnecessary material to
survive 11 moves and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight the G5 with check this is the
move that Magnus missed and he probably
thought okay he can just play Knight to
H5 if G4 it's not a problem but it just
doesn't work for a very specific reason
in that specific reason has to be
pronounced in French and now we have H
captors on G5 this is the only move for
Magnus you cannot move the king H
captures H captures and G5 opens up a
discovery from The Rook so the King
again no squares you can play Bishop to
H6 it's a bit of a sturdier defense but
you know the end result will be the same
here here Magnus plays Knight the H5 and
now also the move that most likely
Magnus missed in all of this madness
when he played King to H7 uh probably
expecting G4 but that would be good for
black but Ludwig it just goes for Rook
captures on H5 with check leaving
magnets with only two options and none
of them are really good if you play
Bishop to H6 it's a matter of simple
Rook captures and H6 check King to G7
Rook D calculus and h8 and you will not
be able to stop Checkmate on the next
move so Magnus of course accepts The
Rook uh G captures on H5 was played and
now look at this bishop to E4 with check
leaving Magnus with only one move and
that is Pawn to F5 and now of course you
all know what's coming uh a beautiful uh
I'll pass on Checkmate and not even with
the G captures and F6 remember if you
give up the H6 Square then the king can
come to H6 but here Hammer just played e
captures on F6 Alpha Song and uh of
course this is now a Checkmate you
cannot go to H6 you cannot go to G8 and
the bishop delivers Checkmate so you you
capture a pawn and deliver a beautiful
bishop checkmate so uh Magnus suffered
some some big loss processing in the
past and he even was on the receiving
end of some very interesting checkmates
but I do not believe he ever suffered
one quite like this so that's why I said
I I I tried to find the happiest photo
of hammer possible but like I said I
imagine he was much much happier when he
played this and he tweeted right after
that on Twitter I just beat Magnus with
an upper sound Checkmate I just peaked
considering retirement as well whoever
whoever does this probably is but of
course he he's probably not going to
retire but I mean it's definitely not
easy to stop this you didn't just uh you
know beat a check a grand master in this
fashion you defeated the world champion
of everything of classical rapid and
Blitz chess and uh there's just no
topping that how do you how do you top
this that's that's it for your Ludwig
hammer and I I wish him all the best and
you know it will be hard for him to find
excitement in life after this but I
guess it was worth it sir that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it I wish
everyone achieves something like this at
least once in their life it's a very
special moment I would like to thank
rabbit 7 Yoon young Anonymous and
ravishing reptiles YouTube for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check out my
new wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day